foreign
[Music]
for Friday November 25th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
the concept of the metaverse sprung into
the mainstream last year some companies
have started up or refocused their
businesses to work on building hardware
and software for what they see as the
future of the online World a digital
realm where we can hang out work shop
maybe even enjoy all the things we
normally do in the real world
but so far the metaverse has struggled
to live up to its Mega hype at this
year's wsj Tech live event I posed
questions about the metaverse and its
future to two people who've been
outspoken about it Herman narula is the
chief executive of improbable worlds a
provider of metaverse infrastructure and
applications and a big believer in the
potential of the metaverse he even wrote
a book about it
Phil libben is the co-founder and CEO of
two startups artificial intelligence
company all turtles and Video
Communications company
and he's much more doubtful about the
cultural and financial possibilities of
the metaverse here are highlights from
our conversation thank you guys both for
joining me uh Herman I want to start
with you and I want to start with a bit
of news that was reported in the journal
it was that Facebook's or say meta's
metaverse platform had about as many
users as the population of Sioux Falls
and that is to say not very many so what
is meta doing wrong when it comes to the
metaverse and who is the metaverse for
well that's a big question I will say
that the actual number is probably
significantly lower so just for the
benefit of the audience whenever you
hear monthly active users
divide by 10 they get how many people
are actually there on a given day and
divide by 10 again to get a sense of how
many people are there in this moment so
if somebody says they have 200 000
monthly active uses well you know that's
not a lot of people on on an actual
moment-to-moment basis in terms of what
is Facebook doing wrong look it's far
for me to kind of criticize and preach
about what a giant corporation like that
should do but what I would say is there
are a lot of lessons we can already see
from the computer games industry there's
a reason why blizzard and other
companies don't announce titles before
they've found product Market fit and in
the end Horizon worlds is essentially a
video game I mean it's more like a game
than it's like any idea of the metabus
that I would recognize I think
prematurely hailing an unfinished game
as the future of a multi-billion user
cooperation is a really difficult thing
to see working out successfully isn't
the metaverse I mean for gamers they're
the ones who kind of are naturally
attracted to this idea of interacting
online of having you know a different
character isn't that what actually I
don't think it is
um so improbable works with about 60
different Global Publishers we just
worked on the new um Modern Warfare if
you uh if you've seen that and a lot of
other games this isn't really part of
our metaverse business we support these
Publishers develop lots of difficult
multiple problems and over the last
years our metabus businesses kind of
exploded not a single one of our
customers in that space has come from
computer games the reason for that is
video games already work well the
metaverse is the idea at least in my
view that you can start connecting these
experiences together and that's a lot
less interesting to games companies than
it is to say sports leagues or fashion
brands Phil I want to bring you into
this you're a metaverse skeptic so how
do you feel about the idea that the
metaverse is for fashion brands or for
events
I'm not a matter of skeptic I think I'm
more of a metaverse hater
I think uh but but in particular uh look
it's kind of pointless ever like betting
against the broad technology like you
know obviously at some point someone is
going to make something that's going to
succeed and you know can always be able
to tie it back to the metaverse and so
long term I'm always very bullish on
just about every technology I think the
Facebook vision of the metaverse is it's
so stupid it makes me sad
um it it accomplishes nothing
if you're having a hard time really
understanding what wait what are we
talking about again what is this thing
again that's okay for like an hour it's
okay for a day but if like if you find
yourself like it's like a weekend and
you're still not sure and everyone is
saying something you're not sure what it
is like chances are you're not sure
because it's dumb it's really nothing
sometimes the emperor really does have
no clothes okay so apart from maybe
agreeing on meta's abilities let's put
them aside
how is the metaverse going to exist and
I had a colleague frame it as is it
indoors or Outdoors so is it AR VR I
think these are the wrong questions and
they're questions that are prompted by
what you refer to as the incredible
stupidity around you know the discourse
Facebook has cooped around one of us
let's start in a simple Place let's not
even use the word none of us
what kind of experiences do people
desire well the research tells us that
they desire fulfilling experiences I
rant about this in my book they want
experiences that give them feelings of
competence or autonomy or relatedness
they want to feel as though they can
make meaningful choices have meaningful
relationships with people if we're going
to build a new product without using the
m word whatever that new product is if
it involves having experiences online it
better provide people more fulfillment
than they can otherwise receive through
Alternatives including the real world
and including video games so now we can
narrow our scope of discussion quite a
lot what sort of experiences are not
possible today that we should make
possible and how might they relate to
each other
I'll give you an example if you're a
Manchester United fan in Southeast Asia
you've probably never been to well
there's a Manchester United fan right
there um you've probably never been to a
game you've never heard the Roar of the
crowd you've never experienced what it's
like to be surrounded by thousands of
other fans or meet your favorite players
if we could make that experience happen
then that would be desirable that would
be valuable that's not something you can
have today Phil do you buy that do you
think people are going to want to have
the same experiences that they might be
able to in person in a metaverse well I
think I just read Herman's book it's a
very nice vision of of where the world
can go uh which which I buy completely I
think we have some disagreement on a few
things particularly timelines I think
like what you're talking about is not
within the investable Horizon of anyone
in this room I think we're decades and
decades and decades out for for some of
that stuff basically you can have the
experience that you described of going
to a football match
you can do it by going to a football
match and I think it's better for us to
for the collect of us to build a world
where more people can have those
experiences by going physically to the
places that they want by experiencing
the things that they want to experience
maybe not to a particular team maybe to
their local team maybe they can live in
places that have more outdoor space that
have more access to Recreation maybe
they can have jobs that don't force them
to waste all their time commuting or
sitting in traffic and they've got time
for their life and I think like now more
than at any other time in history it's
time to invest in the real world and
really just not try to figure out what
we can do with a with a piece of plastic
duct tape to our face and what about the
brands that are getting into this I mean
we've got what Nike Coca-Cola L'Oreal
are these Brands going to regret their
metaverse Investments yeah yeah yeah
they're going to regret them Nike in
particular because people no matter of
us don't even have feeds I don't know
uh look I think VR is a dead end I think
there are certain experiences that make
sense in VR those experiences are few
those experiences are far between those
experiences have been with us for 20
years
there hasn't been meaningfully new
innovation in VR and there won't be
because uh there's this fallacy that
what people want is more immersion and
actually people don't want immersion
most of the time that's why most of us
spend most of our time on the least
immersive devices possible our phones
instead of you know sitting on big uh in
front of big TVs that's why 3D movies
which have been around since the 60s
have not replaced you know normal movies
but what about AR I mean it's not the
only way to potentially engage in the
metaverse augmented reality I think is
great I think it's well it's not great
yeah it barely exists right now but it
has very high potential and when the
headsets are there when when I can wear
something that's not that much bigger
than glasses and I can actually see all
of you really with my eyeballs and on
top of that have things augmented
superimposed as a way to improving the
current reality not substituting it then
sure there's all sorts of use cases
I mean Herman I want to let you jump in
here because I you know you must have
some thought yeah I'd say
um the bot we agree upon is that
immersion is the wrong goal look at the
most successful games of the last few
years fortnite Roblox Minecraft they
look less sophisticated than games that
came before why is that why would that
be it's because it's not about immersion
the promise of of a well-defined
well-functioning and investable
metaverse is not a VR headset it's
presence it's the idea that you can
interact with the world in more
interesting ways and that interaction
results in fulfilling experiences I
think to dismiss the metaverse is the
same as saying like sport fashion
culture all of that stuff it's just a
waste of time let's focus on the real
world what is the real world we already
live in a world of ideas a mechanism to
turn that world of ideas into something
more accessible more concrete more
useful is certainly a virtuous goal I
will say the thing we haven't talked
about here which is what we should be
talking about what we should be talking
about is digital assets because what's
really changed what really creates
opportunity is that now you said that
Nike L'Oreal and there was another
company you mentioned Coca-Cola
Coca-Cola will regret them out of us
Investments I can't speak to Coca-Cola
and L'Oreal but Nike with their purchase
of artifact one of the most prominent
digital asset Brands and with an
incredible opportunity to create
interactive experiences on top of what
they already do I think it's really
really Brave we'll have to leave it
there Airman Phil thank you guys for
joining us thank you
all right that's it for Tech news
briefing this week our producer is Julie
Chang our supervising producer is Chris
sinsley and I'm your host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
foreign
[Music]
[Music]